そういういろいろこのアクセサリーをつけてあげて
とにかく集中することを可能にしてあげちゃうんですね
そこでマントラもありがたい
ありがたいと思って念じたり念じたりしていて
もし仮すると心が自動的に集中力を作るということはもう可能なんです
それはサマーディ状態なんですね
ですからサマーディっていうのはもうすごいこの集中力のね
阿比達磨の言葉で言えば
一境性という心所なんですけど
その心所がどんどんどんどん強くすることがサマーディなんですね
最初はいろんな工夫が必要なんです
これをもういきなりもう力強く発達するということは
それはありえない 丁寧に育てなくちゃいけないんです
ですから サマーディにはもう何か工夫なければサマーディは生まれません
ですから 仏教ではそういうサマーディ瞑想のいろんな工夫は一つも否定していないんです
マントラとかは仏教ではなかったんだからね
初期仏教ではね それはもう言葉に何かそういう神秘的な力とかね
それはもう最初から捨てたんだけど
仏教ではきちんと言葉を使って瞑想
サマーディ瞑想をするんですよ
ですから そこで問題になるのは
この工夫は工夫の効果なんですね
自分使っている工夫は効果的かないかというぐらいの問題
例えばよく私のよく聞かれますけどね
音楽を聴いて瞑想してもいいんじゃないかと
自分がすごく落ち着きますよとかね
私にはなかなか答えられないんですよ
で なぜかというと 音楽を聴いて
それで心落ち着いてもらって
あのー 一境性が得られるならばそれはいいんだけど
そういう音も必ずありますよ
あるんだけど 問題はこの連中は聞いてる音楽は何ですかと
そこにまた問題があるんですよ
瞑想したがる連中が何か音楽をつけてるでしょ
それは自分好みの音楽であって
それは自分の混乱さに適しているんですね
ある人 私にはもうこれは素晴らしい音楽だと
私はこれを聞いていると瞑想よくできますよと
ちょっと聞いてみてくださいと聞かせてもらったんだけど
私からしたらもうお腹の中から気に障るほど
ものすごい混乱だらけの音なんですね
で そこでやっぱりいい音楽だ聞いてくださいと私には正直には言えないんですね
私は何を考えて やっぱりこの人はもうものすごい
よっぽど混乱しているんだと
心の状態はもう世界戦争と同じレベルだと
だからこういう風な音を聴いても落ち着くんだと
だから本人のものすごい強力な混乱状態だから
いくらかの音で落ち着く
例えば子供たちがもうものすごく
もうなんて言いますか
この感情的なで 互いにものすごい喧嘩しているんだと
それで母親がものすごい怒鳴っちゃうでしょうね
あの怒鳴り声を聞いた途端
みんなさっと落ち着くでしょうし
だからといって母親がずっと怒鳴りっぱなしだったら
子供たちが落ち着くかというと
それはないんですよ あんまりにもこのヒステリーになって兄弟喧嘩しているんだから
もう母がいきなり怒ったと
そこでこのそこでレベルの問題で怒ったところで
それを怒鳴った怒鳴り声を聞いた瞬間であの自分のヒステリーの状態がもう消えちゃって
落ち着いて自分も見えるようになってしまう
それであの効能でというんですか
あの危機感が消えちゃうんですね
さらに落ち着いてほしければ
母が続けて怒鳴るんじゃなくて
他のことを言わなくちゃいけないんですよ
さらに落ち着いてほしくてれば
また違う言葉を言わなくちゃいけないんですね
最終的に互いに喧嘩しないようにしてほしければ
お互いに喧嘩するんじゃなくて
まあ兄弟だからお互いの面倒を見て心配して
もういたわり合うのはもう知識的な立派な行動だよということを説得してあげると
ああなるほど そこでお互いに喧嘩しないようになってくる
でも初めというのは怒鳴り声かもしれませんよ
それからもう落ち着いたら
何のため 何のために喧嘩しているんですかと
喧嘩の目的は何ですかと
次の話を聞かなくちゃいけない
それで話してみたところで
別に大したことがなくて
兄弟喧嘩しているんだから
それからあんた方はこういうことだから喧嘩する
こういうことだから喧嘩するんではなくて
教えてあげなきゃいけない
それでそれがけしからぬ生き方ではないかと
兄弟っていうのはこういうものではないけど
最終的には正しい生き方を教えてあげちゃうと
それで兄弟喧嘩っていう現象が消えて
子供たちが喧嘩しないように落ち着くということはあるんです
ですから それも言葉なんですけど
音なんですけども ですから
よっぽど混乱している人にとっては
どんな音楽もいいかもしれませんし
落ち着いている人にとってはどんな音楽もいいわけじゃないんですね
そこで瞑想は随分発達するための音楽というならば
それは瞑想を上達している人が作っている音楽でないと
効き目がないんです 自分が瞑想状態にして禅定状態作って
その感覚は知っている
どういう感覚かと 自分が心がどのように成長したかと全部わかっている
それは音で表現するならば
普通の心はどんどん落ち着いていて
落ち着いていて 落ち着いていて
最終的には統一的になると
そういうふうに分かった人が音楽を書くならば
別に大変素晴らしいんですけど
世の中にはそういう音楽はないんです
音楽を作る人の基本的な心の状態っていうのは混乱なんです
音楽自体は混乱の仕事なんです
落ち着いてできるものじゃないんですよ
音楽的に何か気持ちが生まれたら
それを表現しなくちゃいけないんですね
それを表現するためには
いろんな音を組み合わせたりとかしなくちゃいけないんですね
かといって 左指も右指もまだ別々に行動しているんだから
その時は足をまた別に行動させなくちゃいけないんだから
だからそれで脳細胞は 4つに分かれてるでしょうに
だから作る人が聞く人は落ち着くかもしれません
ああ 気持ちよかったと言うかもしれませんだけど
作る人はものすごいひどい状態なんですよ
ですから作れないんです
具体的には それでも宗教音楽というものはあるんです
宗教音楽の作り方ありますけど
そこでものすごい統一的な心が生まれるということはないんですけどね
宗教音楽の場合は自我を捨てる
捨てて他人を褒めることの音楽だと賛美歌とかね
でも自我を捨てて神を讃える
そういう感じの音楽を作らなくちゃいけない
それだったら音楽で瞑想できるのは仏教ではないんですよ
神を設定しておかないと
すべてを支配している
誰かを設定しておかないと音楽はできないんですね
でも仏教でもまた音楽はあるんです
それでも仏教の音楽も 2種類あります
1つはお釈迦様を褒め称える音楽がありますよ
音楽だったら三宝を褒め称えるということで
それで一部は音楽は出来上がっちゃうんですね
もう 1つは 音楽というのは貪瞋痴を刺激するんですよ
音楽っていうのは単なるむさぼり
むさぼりと怒りと無知を刺激するものなんです
他の音楽はだいたいないんです
じゃあ貪瞋痴を刺激するんじゃなくて
抑える音楽を作ればどうですかと
働きは全く同じなんですね
例えば欲が出てくる 愛情とか愛とかああだこうだとか
この音楽いっぱいあるとたくさんあるんだから
それからまあ愛ができなくなって悲しみを歌うと
ほとんどその 2つなの
音楽は  1つで悲しみ 感じるんですね
それは怒りなんですけど
日本の演歌とかね まあ全部怒りの音楽で九十パーセントぐらい
まあ数えてないんだけど
いい加減な数字ですけど
たまに耳に入るのはみんな泣いてるんですね
歌いながら だから私は一緒にもう一緒に悲しくなるんじゃなくて
本当に腹が立つんです
何言ってるんですか いい加減にしろと
で もう全然面白くないし
もう別れの歌とかね ばっかりで
そこで人がなんか頭でイメージを作ってね
大変もう自分が恋した人がもう二度と会えないように別れてしまったと
その悲しみを味わって
それは音楽だ 美だと言うんです
そこで怒り で あなたのために死んでも別に惜しくもうどうでもいいやと歌うのは
まああなただけ あなただけ太陽だと
あなたがいると世の中みんな笑ってるんだとかって歌う場合は
この恋の歌なんですね
歌ってそういう二種類に分けちゃいますけどね
そこで恋の歌かわりに
この愛情を捨てること
愛情を離れる感情を作っちゃうと
感情として同じなんですよ
フィーリングとしては
音楽っていうのは楽しく聴くものだから
フィーリングとして同じなんですけど
すごく働きが違うんです
ですから この貪瞋痴ではなくて不貪不瞋痴が生まれてくるように音楽を作れば
そういうのは瞑想に 仏教的な瞑想なんですけど
使えるんです でもこれはなかなか大変難しいんです
それできるのは貪瞋痴の働きを知っている瞑想をしている人々なんですよ
でも決してそういう人は人は音楽を作らないんです
作らない 頭の中で音がないんです
ですから 瞑想して悟った人にちょっと何かちょっと書いてくださいって言ったっても
全然書かない それだったら音楽っていうのは頭の中で何にも音はないです
何も音がない 全く無音の状態は一番いい音楽だと
だから全く無音の状態
心でね 感じられるならば素晴らしいんです
それものすごい素晴らしいんですけど
ですから もうそういう難しい世界で
私にとってはなかなか答えられないんですよ
みんな簡単にこういう音楽どうですかとか聞くんだけど
全然もうそこまで考えてないでしょうに
仏教音楽でもそんなに優れているとは言えないんです
そういう点では ですから
お釈迦様は音楽はやめた方がいいと
簡単に それはもうやめた方がいいと
やめた方がいいと言ってお釈迦様は美に反対した人ではないんです
音楽の世界は随分勉強していましたし
それはよくできたんだから
知ってはいたんだけど
あれはもうやめなさいと
瞑想の手段としてはもう使用できない
ですから この音楽は使わないんです
で あの 声明というあの音楽伝統がありまして
これはまあ大乗仏教というのはにもまあ伝わってあって
まあ弘法大師ですか まあいろいろ工夫して
これはかっこいいやと思って
日本にも紹介しましたけどね
だからまあそういうどこらへんに一般人が人気が作ってくれるかということだけ考えて紹介している仏教だから
大した仏教ではないんだけど
あの とにかく声明というのは
まあインドから入ってきて
声明の場合はこの日本の声明でも聞いてみてください
随分違うんですね 感じが
で こちらまた音楽に戻って戻っていますけどね
音楽に戻っているところはあまり良くないんだけど
でも声明の基本的なところは未だに残っているんです
昨日か一昨日か テレビでちょっとこの真言の高野山のちょっと声明なんとか番組があって
それ最後に二 三分ぐらいは曲一つ流れたんですよ
で それは音楽的に作ってあったんだけど
それでもあの琴の音でも聴くと
しっとじーんと心が落ち着くんですね
それはもうその人がこのお坊さんたちの声明を聞いて
その曲を書いたと で あのバックグラウンドでお坊さんたちが声明を仏教を上げたりはするという感じで
やっぱりその分だけでも
あ これも聞いて面白いなとは感じるんですけどね
で 声明の場合は まあ貪瞋痴を抑える風な感じで音が作るんですね
ですから 音楽とは随分違うし
今の現代使っている楽器は使えない
一つも だから楽器なしにやらなくちゃいけない
それすごいもう能力が必要なんですよ
まあとにかくそういうふうな
まあ余計な話なんですけど
音楽については で いくらかは効き目があるかもしれません
それは個人個人の差があるし
ヨーロッパの音楽を聴いて落ち着く人がいるかもしれませんし
東洋の音楽を聴いて落ち着けるというかもしれない
だから決定的なものではないんですね
自分が落ち着くんだから
同じ音楽を聴いて他の人も落ち着くっていうこともまたないし
ハレーラーマハレークリシュナという宗教団体
新興宗教団体あるんですね
インドから始めてアメリカに発展して
アメリカに本山があって
日本でもありますけどね
あの連中がハレーラーマハレークリシュナそればっかり育ってるんですね
それでもう盆勝ちの状態が生まれてくるんだと
だからこれ決まってる音だから
ずっとそれ繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して繰り返して
もう朝から晩まで歌ってる
いろいろ曲歌ってるわけでもないんですね
ただハレーラーマハレークリシュナそれだけ
で 神の名前だけだからね
いくらかの瞑想効果があるかもしれません
それに踊ったりするでしょうし
楽器使ったりするでしょうし
それでゆっくり歌ったり
速く歌ったり でっかい声で歌ったり
踊りながら歌ったり 道路で歩きながらあれで行きながら歌ったりとか
新宿とかね そういう渋谷とか
そういうところで もうど真ん中で人々の真ん中で歌ったりとか
いろんなことをやったりして
自分たちがこの何か心の何か感じようと思ってるんですね
みんな感じをしているのは
もうちょっとしたこの心のちょっとした経験なんですね
これをまあ何といいます
一挙性というかね 一挙性を感じをしているんですよ
それはサマーディということなんですけども
ですから このサマーディにはランクがだから確実にあるんです
サマーディはどんなサマーディも同じってことじゃないんです
それはもう何によって集中したかってぐらいで
その力で終わっちゃうんで
ですから音楽使っちゃうと
その音楽自体にどれまでその人を落ち着かせてあげることができるかって
その決まってるんで それ以上はできないんだと
だからマントラ使っても
そのマントラにはここまではできますよという
このもうやっぱりあるんです
だからそういう場合は
このまあ基本的なところはもう概念を抑えることだから
意味があってはいけないんですね
例えば音楽だと思って
いろんな音楽 いろんな歌書いちゃったら
瞑想音楽にならない ですからハレーラーマハレークリシュナハレークリシュナハレーラーマそれだけ
それにはクリシュナはこういうこういう人だと
だから私はこういう風にクリシュナ神様にまあもうすがって生活します
そういうふうに音が言葉入っちゃったら効き目がなくなっちゃうんです
概念働きますから そこでヒンドゥーの世界で一番有名なマントラはオームでしょうし
オームというのはあいうだけですからね
文字 3つまとめてオームと言うんです
何の意味もないんです
あってどんな意味ですかね
いはどんな意味ですかね
うは？ですね それは基本的に喉が作る音なんですね
それまとめてオームと
基本的に喉が作る音だから
それは 宇宙の創造だとか
オームで全ては作ったとかね
そういう概念を使っちゃうと
瞑想の効き目が消えちゃうんですね
その何も使わないで いろんなやり方でオームということを唱えちゃう
オーム唱える連中のやり方を見ると
真剣真面目でもう長い息を吸って
ずーっともうもう秒ぐらいものび伸ばして伸ばして
ゆっくりと もういろんなやり方ありますけどね
高いトーンで始めて どんどんどんどんトーンを低くして低くして
ギリギリのところまで低くするとか
低いトーンで始めてずっと低いトーンでつなげるとかね
あるいは低いトーンで始めて
どんどんどんどんできるだけ上がって
また最低のところまで下がるとか
いろいろいろんな工夫しながらやってます
大勢の人々と一緒にやっちゃうと
まあ別に感じとして悪い感じもしませんし
そこに何も意味がない場合は落ち着くんです
意味が入れちゃうと効き目がない
これブラフマがオームといて全てのことを創造したんだからって
我々はあれは死ぬまでやったって何一つも創造できませんだけど
大根一本も創造はできませんだけど
まあそういうことで この統一性を作るということには
いろいろ工夫を使う とにかく
工夫を使って統一性を作る
それで工夫に工夫がなしに統一できた状態がサマーディと呼ぶんです
そちらもどんどん力を強くすることも可能なんです
だからこの工夫のレベルを見て
この段階に仏教でサマーディ分けているんですね
色界ではアビダンマではですけど
色界はつと無色界はつと
アビダンマ的に言えば段階なんですね
そこで番目のサマーディというのはヴィタッカヴィチャーラ
頭で考えている言葉使っているレベルなんですね
言葉使いながら統一している状態
それから番目 アビダンマ的に言えば
言葉を使わなくても 現象は概念は取っている状態で
それは可能か不可能かわかりませんだけど
一つの段階としてアビダンマで言ってるんですね
お経ではそれを全部カットして
言葉全くなしに 何かの現象に対処することができる状態が番目の禅定であって
それでつなげているのは喜びとか喜悦感とかね
それで喜びが引き金になっちゃう
喜びが感じているんだから
統一することができやすくなっちゃうんですね
そこで喜びが感じなくても統一することまで
いわゆるシャーの状態
で統一するところまで発達する
それから何か対象現象をとっているんだから
何も対象現象なしに心の統一性も作られるかというのは無色界なんですね
あれはもうものすごい難しいと思います
今 いろんな宗教の人々の神秘的な体験とか
全部そろって見て考えてみたっても
無色界の禅定が作ったなというふうには感じられないんですね
色界の禅定がはもう結構あるようには感じますけどね
それは私の概念であって
別にだからといってそれは真実ということは言いませんだけどね
わかりませんからね 無色界の場合は何も現象がないんですね
頭の中に だから番目は空無辺だからね
空無辺情というんですからね
空という もう空間ですか
空間という言葉で それも一つの色界の言葉ですけど
心では何も取ってないような状態で落ち着いているとかね
そこをまたさらに進んでいって
色無辺とかね いろいろありますけど
最終的には心の働きは全部抑えて
統一の働きだけ強烈な認識的な働きも抑えていく
それはまあ何でしたっけ？ネーサンニャーナーサンニャーとなって非想何とかですね
非想非想想 そういうことで
とにかくこの精神性にはこの
育てるということは可能であって
育てれば育てるほど心が強くなっていくんです
で 知恵を知恵が絡んでいるんだから
このヴィパッサナーの場合は
そこら辺で瞑想のやり方は少々違うんですね
知恵育てるということはサマーディ瞑想ではないんです
サマーディ瞑想に知恵関係ないといえばそうじゃないんです
知恵は関係ありますけど
知恵を育てるということは別にはしない
とにかく統一してサマーディ作るという目的なんです
体験してしようと この知恵という精神の働きと矯正というの精神の働きが違うんですね
知恵っていうのは知ることなんですね
ですから知るということを育てるんですね
体験するのではなくて
それにはサマーディが確実に必要なんです
ですから サマーディとパンニャーが一緒に育てて
同じ力 同じレベルになると
出世賢心が可能になっちゃうんです
そこでこの 出世賢心にどんな風に信者が生まれるかとか
大信どのように生まれるかとか
そのテキストは続けてますけど
そこら辺は別に 必要かどうかちょっとわからないんですけど
で 一応それで 第2章終わりにしようかなとは思ってますけど
どうしても知りたいというならば説明はできますけど
一人一人の心にどのように信者が生まれるかと
実践的な立場から説明しなくちゃだからアビダンマっていうのは
やっぱりこの瞑想のこの七覚支の七覚支をしなくちゃいけないんだから
この 2番目の択法覚支を育てるための働きなんですよ
ですから それだけのことなんですけど
やっぱりこのこれは何ですか
これは何ですかと理解しておかなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから そこら辺では混乱が生まれたりはする
例えばこの自分の瞑想を進んでいる人々が
単なる妄想 妄想だとかね
言葉を入れたっても それはあまり基本的でもう
そんなに意味がないんですね
この間私に質問されたんだけど
この心に起こるものは全部妄想ですか？と
いくらかは妄想だとはわかりますけど
別に自分でワサワサするんじゃなくて
勝手にいろんなこと見えたり感じたりするのは
そういうのは全部妄想ですかと聞いて
私は怒りましたけどね
余計なことを考えるなと
で で そこでまあ説明したのはまあ妄想ってなんですかということなんですね
で 心に心の働きは基本的には妄想だと見てもいいんだけど
で 妄想っていうのは 私が言ってるのは
あんた全部妄想だと聞くよりは
あんた実相ってなんですか？知ってますかと
妄想というのは実相という言葉から成り立ってるんだから
妄だから妄想の代わりに実相って入れなくちゃいけないでしょうに
じゃあこれは実相 これは妄想と
そんな確認できるかないかと
そこでじゃあ見える聞こえる音とか痛みとかね
それは妄想で見ないし
頭で何か妄想したらそれだけ妄想と思ったりしちゃうしね
だからそこら辺はもうちょっと複雑なんですよ
そこまで心 人間の心は鋭いかどうかは私はわかりませんし
例えばこの耳に音が入るでしょ
その瞬間にもう音 車の音か客車の音かってもうわかってるでしょうね
それは妄想でしょうし
客車の音というものあるわけじゃないし
音っていうのは波であって
一つのそろ そろしであって
それは耳に触れるんであって
そのレベルで理解した方が真理であって
でもそれはできますかね
ある程度で音視という言葉はないかもしれませんだけど
まあ光視という言葉はありますけど
まあ音視使っても構いませんし
仏教的なだってある程度の量の音視が音の粒が耳に触れておかないと反応しないし
我々の聴覚が ですから聴覚が反応すると
もうすでにそれは妄想になってるんです
それだったら音入ったら妄想と
痛みが出たら妄想と 何か出たらもうそれ瞑想にならないで
それだったら ですから
このヴィパッサナー瞑想の進み方はもうちゃんとありますから
その通りにやった方がいいんですね
その通りにやるとじわじわと進むんですよ
だから智慧と智慧が発達する度に
この観察するラベリングの
ラベリングのやり方が変わっていくんです
それはやっぱり自然の流れに任せておいた方がいいんです
わざわざ自分の頭に起こる考え方は
これはもう妄想じゃないんだ
これは本物の実相だ これどうやってわかるんですかね
それは わかるわけじゃないし
だからどちらが妄想か
どちらがそうでないかともわからないし
だから適当にラベリングしなくちゃいけない
だからこの指導の場合は
このみんなこの納得いかない
あの指導者が良くないとか
なんとかとか偉そうなことを言うんだけどね
それ絶対言ってはいけない言葉なんですけど
例えば自分が何か素晴らしい光が感じるんだと言ったら
指導者言うのはそれをちゃんと確認したんですか？と
ラベリングしたんですか？と
はい 光光とラベリングしましたと言うんだよ
ああ それだったらそれで結構と
それだけなんですよ でも瞑想する人がそこで納得いかないんですね
褒めてほしい これはどういう光か解釈してほしい
自分がどこのところまで発達しているか説明してほしい
位置付けてほしいと それをやらないんです
それはないし そうするとヴィパッサナーにならないんですね
ただ確認することだけ
サティを入れることだけしちゃうと
妄想の世界を破ることはできるんですよ
妄想のレベル消えたら
実相見えた瞬間でもうすぐもう悟りの世界なんです
それには妄想にとらわれないということは必要なんですね
とらわれたら自分が進めなくなっちゃうし
だから たとえ何があろうとも確認して続けなさいということしか言えないんですね
まあそういうことで この妄想の世界破るためには
択法覚支という七覚支の番目の働きなんですけど
それは必要なんですね
分離して分析して見なくちゃいけない
ですから 怒りが生まれたら
ああ これは怒りですと理解する必要あるんです
怒りを抑えることでも
育てることでもどうでもないんです
すごいクールな心で ああ
これは怒りです これは欲ですと
これは昏沈睡眠ですと
そういう風にラベリングするぐらいの
知識ですか あってほしいんですね
アビダンマでそれなんです
やってるの それもどれほど世界が大きいかというと
もう言うともうすごいすごい世界なんです
ラベリング可能なぐらいの知識
大変ものすごい大きな世界なんですよ
で 例えば頭の中でヴィパッサナーできるようになってきたら
妄想 妄想と言って また膨らみついて戻ったり
また他のことに行ったり
また妄想持ったりしたりしたりすると
まあどこかで空回りするようになってくるかもしれません
空回りになってくるならば
もうちょっと進んで 妄想ではなくて
今むさぼりの概念 今怒りの妄想
今無知の妄想とか それぐらいのラベリングすることができれば
もう大変なことなんですよ
だからそれは妄想もずっと流れていくので
もうもうかなり妄想したところで
妄想だと気がつく状態ではできるものじゃないんです
妄想が生まれたら すぐ妄想ということをわかって
まあこれは欲の妄想とラベリングできると
それぐらいでも大変な状態なんですよ
そこで これはむさぼり
これは怒り これは無知と区別できるためには
これぐらいの量を勉強しておかないと難しいんです
ですから そのぐらいの知識あればいいと
例えば自分が嫉妬が生まれたら
自分妄想 全部妄想ではなくて
この認識の働きですから
ですから 妄想というよりは認識の回転と言った方が正しいんです
概念の回転 人間っていうのは見る
聞く 味わう 体で感じる
鼻で嗅ぐ それから頭で概念が回転する
その 3つの 6つの働きが人間だよと理解した方がもっといいと思いますよ
妄想という言葉を使うよりは
なぜならば パーリ語では妄想という言葉はないんです
パーリ語の言葉を使ってヴィパッサナー瞑想するならば
妄想という言葉出てこない
まあありますけどね あまり使わないだろうと思います
それはもう大変哲学的な言葉なんです
パーリ語である妄想という言葉は
日本語で使っている妄想みたいな
もうすごい単純明快な意味ではないんです
パーリ語の妄想の言葉というのはパパンチャという言葉であります
パパンチャっていうのはこの現象ということで
ものは現象で認識することはパパンチャなんですね
真理で認識することはニッパパンチャという
ニッパパンチャというのは涅槃なんですね
ですから 妄想が生まれたら
今はパパンチャですよと認識したってもう効き目がないんです
使わないんです えーと
ヴィパッサナーの世界っていうのは
思うほど簡単単純じゃないんですよ
説明しちゃうとも で まあですから妄想
妄想ではなくて 妄想はすぐつかまえられる
瞑想すると 生まれたらすぐ妄想と確認できる
で それ上手にできるようになったところで
瞬時にこれは欲の これは怒りの妄想
これは無知の妄想やと 3つに分けられるぐらいになっちゃうと
もうかなり知恵っていうのはもう育てるんですね
必要な知恵 だからこの五力の知
知の力がここないと育ててこないんですね
そこでそれも順番がありまして
一番わかりやすいのはもしかすると怒りの妄想かもしれません
嫌な妄想が出ちゃうと怒りと置いておく
怒りの妄想と それからなんか気持ちよく妄想しちゃうと
それは欲の妄想と 妄想で言ったっても
あまり妄想と意味に行くんじゃなくて
妄想というか あるかどうか私もわかりませんだけど
ただ認識が回転する それは止まることはできないんです
目が開けたら見えることは止められますか？って
止まれませんでしょうに
耳がある人に耳に音が触れることは止まられますか？って
止まれませんし 耳がある
外の世界に音がある そこで聴覚が生まれる
止まれませんし 心があるんだから
そこで概念が回転する
みんな妄想という変な解釈をつけちゃって
それで止まってほしいとかね
思ってやってるんだけど
まあ私はそんな無駄な努力は知ってますけどね
で そこをまあ最初はそれでいいんですけど
進んじゃうと この妄想というところじゃなくて
それも見る聞くと同じ一つの働きなんですね
生命の それを止まることは不可能なんですね
そこで認識の流れが欲の流れか怒りの流れかと
まずそれをふうに 2つに分けてみて
それからその 2つに分けられない妄想もありますね
認識の流れがあるんですね
それは無知に入れてみると
それもうまく上手にできないんですよ
大変難しいんです よっぽど集中力必要なんです
だから念サティからサマーディの定力ですか
それ出てこなくてもないと
それ出てきちゃうときちんと見られる
そこで次はまた大変な問題が
ものすごい壁が壁に当たっちゃうんです
それやり始めたら 壁に当たってまたからまりなっちゃうんです
それどういう壁かというと
瞑想している途中だから
確実にむさぼりと怒りと無知だけ生まれてくるならば
妄想として便利なもんなんですよ
明確にラベリングできるんです
でも残念ながら サティを入れるたびに心は先進性なんですよ
サティで確認しちゃうと
その瞬間で先進性なんですね
だから今の今は欲の妄想だと言った瞬間であるのは欲の妄想じゃないんです
そこをすっごいごちゃ混ぜになっちゃってわからなくなっちゃうんです
だから次に必要なのは不貪不瞋不痴の概念も認識する能力なんですよ
貪瞋痴はわかりやすい
日常茶飯事にあるものだから
貪瞋痴認識できたところで
不貪不瞋不痴も だから瞑想する人がずっと欲だけで怒りだけ頭の中でいっぱいあるわけじゃないでしょ
瞑想あまりうまくいかないと
怒りやら欲やら出てくるんだけど
うまくいっちゃうと どうせそれできるのはうまくいってる人なんですよ
貪瞋痴に分けることもできるのはうまく進んでいる人なんですね
それうまく進んでいる人だから
もう不貪不瞋不痴の概念も生まれてくるんで
それ妄想ですけど 妄想と言いたければ
ですから妄想と言わないで
認識の回転だと言った方が正しい言葉なんですね
今認識はむさぼりの方向に回転している
今怒りの方向へ回転している
今無知の方向へ回転していると
今不貪の方へ回転していると
今不瞋の方へ回転していると
そこで不痴ですか この痴
無知がない状態は いわゆる智慧の状態なんですね
明確に確認できる状態は
まあ不貪不瞋不痴状態なんですね
阿摩羅婆の状態なんですね
なかなか難しいんですよ
ヴィパッサナーするっていうことは阿摩羅婆の状態なんです
難しいんだけど やらなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからこれ大変な仕事なんです
ものすごい 世の中でこれほど難しいことはないんです
これわずかでもできるというのは
他のことって何のことなくできるんですよ
外科の先生のような感じで
一つ一つ別々別になん